one of the big issues in this
presidential election is going to be
January 6th it's in the news now and I
think it's going to get become bigger
and bigger and bigger so question for
Destiny first did Donald Trump Insight
an Insurrection on January 6th
2021 absolutely uh this is probably
ignoring every other issue we've talked
about if which I think there are plenty
that I would say disqualify Trump from
holding office um I think that the
conduct and the behavior you're leading
up to and including January 6th I think
is wildly indefensible I am excited to
see Ben try to uh yeah the uh the the
three to four stages are the um the
taking what I think any reasonable
person say knowingly false information
about elections being rigged or ballot
boxes being stuffed or Ruby Freeman you
know running ballots three times in
Georgia taking that knowingly false
information and trying to call uh State
secretaries and stuff to to have them
flip their electoral a vote that was
horrible um the plot that eastmen
hatched in order to have these like
false slates of electors where all seven
states had citizens go in and falsely
say that they were the duly elected uh
electors that could submit votes to
Congress that was insane uh that
happened um asking or begging Pence to
accept these false states of electors
initially and then just say you should
just throw it out completely and throw
it to the house ation which was majority
Republican that was absolutely
unbelievable and then on the day of
January 6th trying to capitalize on the
Violence by him Giuliani and Eastman
making phone calls to senators and
congressmen saying well don't you think
maybe you guys should delay the vote a
little bit you know don't you think
they're just really mad about the
election I think he said to McCarthy
they're more upset than you um and and
his utter dereliction of Duty and not
doing anything to uh stop the the
rioting that happened on January 6
because he was too busy taking advantage
of it I think all of these things are
horrible uh I look forward to seeing the
uh jacksmith indictments play out in
court uh maybe even the Georgia REO case
but um yeah I think all of these things
are un unfathomable and I think when you
look at the plot from start to finish
clearly the goal the entire time was to
circumvent the peaceful transfer of
power that was the goal from start to
finish whether it was through false
claims whether it was through illegal
schemes or whether it was through
violence at the capital to delay the
certification of the vote Ben so I'm
glad you're excited it's always fun so
um there are two elements to incitement
of insurrection one is incitement the
other is Insurrection uh so incitement
has a legal standard so does
Insurrection neither of those standards
are met so if you're asking me morally
speaking did Donald Trump do the right
thing between November 4th and January
6th I said I will continue to say no he
did not I think he was saying things
that are false uh with just factually
false about his theories with regard to
the election about the election being
stolen about fraud this is all
adjudicated in court he did not even
bring many of the claims that he was
brought publicly and all the rest of
that if we're talking talking about
incitement of insurrection is a legal
standard doesn't meet any of those
standards when it comes to incitement it
has to be immediate law incitement to
immediate Lawless action that's the
standard for incitement and I'm very
meticulous in how I use this because I
happen to speak publicly a lot and that
means there are lots of people who
listen to me which means some of those
people are probably crazy and some of
them may go and do a crazy thing did I
incite them the media tend to use the
word incitement very Loosely with regard
to this sort of stuff in the same way
that Bernie Sanders quotequote incited
the Congressional baseball shooting he
did not B Bernie Sanders has a lot of
things I disagree with I think Bernie a
schmuck doesn't matter he did not incite
that so saying bad things is not the
same thing as inciting violence inciting
violence the legal standard of the
United States is I want you to go punch
that guy in the face that's that's
inciting uh with regard to Insurrection
typically in Insurrection and there are
some descriptions in case law though
none in statutory law as far as I'm more
the typical description in case law is
the replacement of one legitimate
government of the United States with
another by violent means the the notion
that Donald Trump coordinated any such
Insurrection is Bel lied by the FBI
itself the FBI put out a report in uh I
believe it's was August of 2021
suggesting that there was no
well-coordinated insurrectionist attempt
coordinated by the white house uh in
fact what you had was Donald Trum
thrashing around like that weird alien
in the movie life I don't know if you
ever saw it with Jake jolen hall or is
like kind of thrashing up against this
glass box just an alien just thrashing
up against the glass box uh that that
that I think is is more what you were
seeing from November 4th to January 6th
um and then again the claim that January
6th itself was an Insurrection so
virtually I'm not aware that anyone was
charged with actual Insurrection there
were some people who were charged with
seditious conspiracy there are
Insurrection statutes that do exist no
one was charged under those particular
statutes um you know the there were some
people who you could say informally had
insurrectionist ideas those would be the
people who wanted to hang Nancy Pelosi
or kill Mike Pence and those people are
in jail right now uh and the election
went forward the election was certified
Mike Pence presided over the
certification Mitch McConnell presided
over the certification Joe Biden has
been the president for the last three
years so the Donald Trump by the way was
still president at that point if he had
actively wanted to do what other people
who have actually launched coups have
done he would have theoretically called
the National Guard not to put down the
riot but to actually depose the the
sitting government of the United States
in the name of a specious legal theory
he did not do that he did not attempt
that nobody working for him did that the
the most you can say I think about what
everybody was doing is that you know and
I want to say everybody we can talk
about Trump because this is really about
Trump he used a phrase that that Trump
was disseminating knowingly false inform
the word that's carrying a lot of weight
there is the word knowingly um so
knowingly implies a no do I think the
information he was dissing was false yes
so I think that Donald Trump has a
unique capacity to convince himself of
nearly anything that is to his own
benefit absolutely and I think that
that's actually what Donald Trump was
doing there and the evidence of that is
Donald Trump being a human and all of us
watching him for the last several years
uh so you know the the idea that that he
knew it to be false I'm not even sure
those standards apply in any like I just
assessing him as a human which is really
what we're being asked to do because
there's an intent element to to this
crime does Donald Trump do you think
that today Donald Trump knows that he
lost the election absolutely so I I
don't actually I think but when we so
I'm glad that you have the attorney
background when we are assessing Manera
when we're looking at certain criminal
statutes where intent is required it's a
reasonable person standard right like
would a reasonable person have known
that they were no it depends on the men
right standard so it's not the same in
every case if you have to establish
individual intent then it's enough to
say a reasonable person should have
known that would be enough for a
negligent statute usually when you're
talking about reasonable people person
statutes just legally speaking a
reasonable person statute is should a
reasonable person have known that's when
you get to like manslaughter you can't
do a reasonable person standard on like
first-degree murder you have to
establish actual motive in first degree
murder but for first-degree murder you
don't need the statement of I plan to
kill this person or I intend to kill
this person we can prove that State of
Mind ccal evidence correct yes sure you
can prove it so I feel like my my
feeling for Donald Trump was there were
all these people around him that he
trusted to investigate election fraud he
trusted bar and the doj he asked Pence
his vice president to look into it he
asked his chief of staff he has his
legal counsel has so many people that
ostensibly he trusts them if he's asking
them to look into it and when all of
them looked into it and reported back to
him no we found nothing what and unless
we're going to literally make the
concession that Trump might actually be
a delusional psychoan at that point
should he not have realized like well
okay maybe that's thing he should have
realized the day of the election that he
lost the election but that's not but
that but I'm just I'm saying that like
at that point should he not have known
that for him to go and propagate those
claims that he' asked all of the people
he trusted to research and then for him
to take those claims to uh Michigan and
to Georgia and then publicly and to try
to convince people to throw out the
election you don't think that but you're
doing the same thing you're reverting to
should a reasonable person have known
yes a reasonable person should have
known did Donald Trump know that's
that's that's a different that's a
different question and so conflating
those two questions is going to get you
into some by the way this is why Jack
Smith charged the way Jack Smith charged
yeah which was Jack Smith did not charge
conspiracy Jack Smith did not charge
Insurrection he did not charge Sous
conspiracy right if he the reason is
because Jack Smith is a good lawyer what
he's doing is he's actually broadly I
would say pretty obviously expanding
statutory coverage in weird areas in
order to cover a thing that doesn't
quite fit into any of these legal
categories but the point that I'm making
is that Jack Smith is on my side of this
he doesn't think that he can actually
establish the intent necessary to
convict under a seditious conspiracy or
or an Insurrection I agree with that but
I think a lot of the underlying facts
though because he does bring up those
calls to uh raffensberger in Georgia he
does bring up in the indictments that
they they were knowingly false
information so it seems like that's
going to be part of the case maybe not
to convict on any of the four particular
charges that he mentioned but it seems
like that's probably going to be part of
um what he's going to have to establish
in court to convict Trump so I I want to
look at the actual text of the charges
so I I'm sorry that I don't have the
memorize I believe one's a fraud charge
that generally does not apply to cases
like this generally the fraud charge is
like you're trying to steal money from
the government sure fraud has been used
pretty broadly in the past though it
doesn't have to just be because um Smith
has done oral arguments in response to a
lot of the claims by Trump's lawyers
this was one of them the infinite civil
and criminal immunity was another one of
them where he cites past cases where
these types of things because I think it
was to defraud of civil rights I think
was the fourth charge right so the
defraud of civil rights is usually
somebody standing in the actual like
voting house door and preventing you
from voting not you have a specious
legal theory that you espouse in court
about whether those votes should be
thrown out sure um although I don't like
the when we say specious legal Theory
and novel application which I do agree
some of these in some is novel I don't
think we've ever also had a president
try to do this before it is a novel
situation where somebody has resisted
the peaceful transfer of power this
clearly ways well if you're talking
about the legal cases that I mean that's
not true but G Gore suit in 2000 I mean
so that so like if talking the legal
comparable to gore if this was
comparable to gore I'm not saying it's
comparable to gore I'm saying that if
the idea is that espousing a legal
theory in court amounts to de facto some
form of election denial or interference
in some way that that can't that that's
not as a general principle it's over
inclusive sure Gore wasn't trying to
desertify the vote though for States
right they challenged their thing to the
Supreme Court they lost their case in
the Supreme Court and then power
transfer happened after and Donald Trump
had a bunch of legal challenges and then
he had a rally and then there was a riot
and then he left power yeah but the but
the Eastman theory of what Pence could
do in Congress is a far cry away a truly
shitty Theory I mean make no mistake
it's a just shitty I think that if any
Democrat had done this I I think that I
feel like we'd be looking at it in a far
different lens
as in we would be using terms like
attempted coup subversion to Peaceful
transfer of power if um if if a Democrat
vice president had tried to essentially
say that in uh Congress they could throw
away the vote so I think what I want to
get to here actually so we can be more
specific is why are these terms
important we agree on largely speaking
what happened I think the the the
characterization of the term are we are
we we kind of bouncing around between
two different different categories and I
want to make sure legal stuff we looking
at in you said Jacki nobody's charging
with incitement and I don't believe
Insurrection is part so we legal I just
in terms of like a president that is
trying to prevent the peaceful transfer
of power so whether you call that a
bloodless coup or a coup or uh whatever
contemporaneous term you want to use
right so prevent the peaceful transfer
of power with all means or using means
that are inappropriate not quite the
same thing using means that
inappropriate or illegal okay
inappropriate okay so illegal I don't
think so I I don't think that these
charges actually meet the the criteria
for the for the various charges and we
can discuss each case if you want um as
far as inappropriate sure I think in
tons of inappropriate stuff I mean I I
inappropriate seem the reason I don't
like the word inappropriate though is
because then conservatives are very
quick to say well sure he was
inappropriate but everybody was
inappropriate I mean I I'll con that he
was more inappropriate than others I I
just don't see he most inappropriate
sure okay that's important to me though
does it not bother you that like Donald
Trump sought through legal and extr
legal and and Trump magical ways of
trying to entrench his power as
president past when he should have been
able to is that not something that is
incredibly Troublesome I mean the
question to me is the bigger question
that I think the Democrats are trying to
promote in this election cycle which is
this means he is a threat to democracy
sufficient that if he were to win the
election there would not be another is
that but is but that last time could he
not try to next time and I mean he could
try to do whatever he wants presumably
and he would fail the same way that he
did last time why do we think that
because he failed because
so three hours yes like let's say
hypothetically Lord save me uh let's say
hypothetically Giuliani was the next um
head of the Department of Justice
Giuliani was the next Attorney General
how would he be
confirmed um I well I I'm not entirely
sure if uh because so much of the
Republican Party despite feeling like
they don't support Trump when it comes
time to actually back him in Congress
also I would have to check whether he
would be barred by criminal conviction
from holding I don't know the answer to
that sure yeah well yeah we're that's
especially the 14th Amendment we're
figuring out a lot this right now yeah
um but I mean like say if not juliani
say if there are any other number of
insane people that Trump could
theoretically put on his side of the
government that wouldn't tell him no
last uh next time because there were a
lot of people that rebuked him there
were Republicans in in a lot of the
states right raffensberger is one of
them um there were Republicans in his
own Administration uh you've got Rosen
uh you've got bar um there was his own
vice president but like theoretically
next time and I feel like last time
going in I'm going to do a little bit of
mind reading at macro maybe agree maybe
disagree I think that Trump kind of
thought one I don't think Trump knows
much at all about how the government
works I think we probably age with that
um I think Trump probably thought that
if he had people that were like at least
in his party and kind of camp that
they'll basically do whatever needs to
be done to give him what he wants um and
with no respect for process but now that
he sees that well that's it's not enough
to just have allies I need people that
are fiercely Allegiant to me would we
not be worried that a guy that tried to
essentially steal the election for real
wouldn't try to pick people that would
be more amable to his plans in the next
Administration I believe in the checks
and balances of American government I
believe they worked on January 6th so if
you're asking me do I think that Trump
has bad intent or could have bad intent
with that sort of stuff sure do I
believe that the guard rails held and
will continue to hold also sure so you
so if somebody was running and they
blatantly said like I um I don't want to
use the fascist word but if they said
like I want to be an authoritarian I'm
going to abolish all elections you would
say sure he saying that but like I don't
think he can actually do it so it's okay
if he runs for president you don't care
at all as long as you feel like the
guard ra I might prefer other candidates
but I think that also one of the things
that you do is that politicians again
this would be an exceptional
circumstance but politicians constantly
make promises about the things that they
are going to do and then don't fulfill
and we tend to take those out in the
wash meaning that you know the if I
promise that day one as Donald Trump has
pledged to do that he's going to deport
literally every legal immigrant in the
country do I think he's actually going
to do that I mean I I really highly
doubt it he didn't do it last time he
was office that's just there are many
examples of this do I do I think here's
my question do you think the guard rails
are going to fail to hold I'm not sure
uh really yeah because I think the issue
is is one um when it's election time
Republicans are spineless in office um
and I don't know how many Congressmen
would support what he wants just because
they want to win re-election or because
they think it's inevitable anyway well I
mean I think that one of the one of the
things that happened in 2022 is
Democrats ran directly on this platform
and a bunch of Republicans lost who
running on this platform literally every
secretary of state ran on the Donald
Trump we should deny elections platform
lost in every state sure but other
republic office is this sure but I mean
like look at what happened with like
kensinger kensinger and Cheney right who
had were very like stly antitrump after
j6 uh for that select committee right
kininger didn't even run again and
Cheney lost her election but I think the
widest margin that anybody has ever lost
an election ever like all of us politics
people who were not yet born voted
against yes I guess it's just it's a
surprising position to me for if we're
looking at like principal stances of
government the idea that a man who has
and I think we both agree on this that
Donald Trump's Donald Trump's only
Allegiance is to Donald Trump right we
agree on that the only thing he cares
about is Donald Trump I don't the only
thing you care about I think it's
certainly the largest thing he care it's
the largest thing he cares about right
so if you've got a man who only cares
about himself welcome to politics I mean
it's it may be more but that's not even
it may be more with Trump but it's
certainly not unique to Trump I think
that the issue with Trump too though is
um I think he's even a threat to the
Republican party in which I think I
think he would mostly agree with me
maybe not overall but on every
individual Point Trump picks bad
candidates he has no concern for the
future Republican party like for
instance I think there is a chance I
don't think it'll happen because of how
the polling looks now but if Trump
didn't get the nomination I think Trump
would say screw it and run is an
independent because he thinks he can win
or whatever right um I I doubt that he
would do that but theoretically again
Trump has he was really content to throw
Georgia um the two runoff elections
under the bus because rensburg support
him for the election stuff what what is
all this in service of what's the what's
the generalized argument that you're
making do you believe I'll go back to my
question do you think that if Trump wins
there will be no more elections is that
is that like what what percentage on it
what what percentage do you think that
that's a reality that if Donald tral
Trump wins I think there is a 100%
chance that he will try to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power in terms of
would he succeed I can guarantee you he
will not do that why is that because
he's in a second term and he's no longer
eligible and he will believe he won and
he will leave yeah but hasn't Donald
Trump himself joked about running for a
third term that's I think that I think
that having a third term what what has
Donald Trump not joked about I mean
forgot I don't okay hold on if you if
you want to prevent if you want to
prevent him from creating a revolution
you probably should just appoint him
president here's another broad argument
that I don't like in favor of trump and
this was brought up earlier in terms of
like we talk about like not grading
presidents on a curve but then earlier
we said we take Biden's R I totally
grade I no I 100% grade presidents on a
curve are you kidding oh okay I grade
pretty much everybody on a curve I don't
treat my seven-year-old the same way
that I treat my nine-year-old sure but
it feels like we're treating Donald
Trump like a seven-year-old or a
nine-year-old I think we should treat
him like the president of the United
States I don't think having a president
that has taken like concrete steps to
prevent the transfer of power which he
did with the electorate Shem which you
did with Pence and which you did with
trying to capitalize on the j6 violence
a president that's taken concrete steps
towards uh couping the government
essentially I don't know why that guy
we'd say well you know it's Trump he
does Trump things the guard rails held
I'll probably hold next when we say we
shouldn't do you mean that he should be
actually barred from office I'm just
talking about support for him I don't
think Republicans should should support
Trump you lose your incumbent Advantage
the guy's obviously self-destructive
he's destructive the political party
itself like um you think he should be on
the ballot um you think there's a case
to be made to remove him from the ballot
I think there's a case to be made but
man the phrasing for as much as our uh
governmental founding fathers everybody
else you know wrote nice amendments and
wrote nice in the Constitution some of
the phrasing is very very very and the
uh section three um the the the not
requiring any type of actual conviction
um I don't have a strong feeling on it I
will say I'm very interested in reading
the majority opinion from the Supreme
Court I seriously doubt the Supreme
Court is going to uphold that states
should be able to decide if they leave
them off The Ballot or not um I think
for the political future of the United
unit States it's probably not healthy
that the leading opposition candidate is
now going to be barred from the ballot
is probably not healthy for us um
because because then what you talk about
threats to democracy that would be a
pretty serious one applied across the
board by it would be however like that
threat to democracy was earned by Donald
Trump and the conservatives that
supported him I think conservatives made
a dangerous gamble when they threw Trump
into office and now like all of the
Fallout from that is is something that
we all As Americans have to deal with I
mean I I I think that the the
unprecedented legal theory that a state
can simply Barrow somebody from the
ballot on the basis of in an informal
way believing that he is quote unquote
an insurrectionist is is pretty wild I
mean that's that that we can say it's
pretty well but there is an amendment in
the Constitution the 14th amendment that
says that if they have engaged in this
they shall not be or you shall I don't
remember the phrasing because it doesn't
require conviction but it's a
self-executing arguably thing if we're
getting into constitutional law I mean
there there there are a number of
Provisions that that suggest that this
is number one not self-executing the
minority opinions in the in the Colorado
Supreme Court case are are pretty
thorough uh the the number one
contention which is that this is not
self-executing uh because other elements
are not self-executing that ignores
subsequent actual law that that happened
I mean the Congress passed a law for
example in 1872 defining who was an
insurrectionist who is not an
insurrectionist for perspectives of
elections in 1994 Congress passed a law
that specifically defined Insurrection
as a criminal activity so that somebody
could theoretically be convicted of
insurrection and therefore ineligible to
run for office it is unlike say the the
the analogues that are used by the
majority opinion like age obviously this
is not the same thing we can all tell
what somebody's age is by looking at
their birth certificate I can't tell
whether somebody's an insurrectionist
without any reference to a legal statute
or definition of the term I would also
say be careful with that because
remember one of Trump's first like big
political actions was challenging
Obama's birth certificate well and and I
thought that was dumb at the time but I
like that you both said 100% chance that
Trump will try to go for third term and
0% chance which statis third term he's
done man are you kidding he would want
to Trump's going to walk around hands up
highs like I'm a two-term president I'm
the only President since Grover
Cleveland he would know but but since
Grover Cleveland who served two
non-consecutive terms I kicked Joe Biden
out of office and I kicked Hillary
Clinton out of dude would be like he'd
be living large are you kidding he
doesn't want the presidency anymore
after that I just think that the I think
it's scary that like Donald Trump it
feels like for all of the accusations
that are made sometimes against
Democrats like Biden is ordering uh
Garland to investigate Donald Trump and
blah blah blah uh it seems like Donald
Trump would actually do that with his
doj would give them orders he didn't he
didn't he he kind of did though right um
so for instance with um Jeffrey Clark uh
Jeffrey Clark went to Rosen and you and
said Hey listen uh I need you guys to
sign off on a letter that we're going to
use essentially to bully States into
overturning their elections by saying we
found significant election fraud and
part of that threat was Jeffrey Clark
saying listen if you're not going to do
it Rosen uh you know Trump's going to
fire you and just make me the uh acting
attorney general that was a threat that
he carried and I think Trump repeated
that threat in a meeting later on that
was I only rebuked when I think like
half the White House staffs that if you
do this were resigning okay so that's a
slightly different topic because now
you're getting into all the election
Shenanigans and all this but saying he
threatened to fire his acting attorney
general if he wouldn't carry the same
platform essentially like if Trump could
order his doj to do something would he
um it's not Beyond The Pale for him
right it's not Beyond The Pale for him
to order them to do it and then it's not
Beyond The Pale for them to reject him
doing that which is the story of his
entire Administration whereas Joe Biden
ERS his doj to do things and then they
just do them well I'm not we can get
into specifics there um I I just I it
this is one of the big problems that I
have with I mean for example all the
talk about Trump Tyrant Trump executive
power I mean Joe Biden has used
executive power in ways that far
outstrip anything has been stretching
and stretching and stretching executive
power Jo Joe Biden is going like Joe
Biden has gone well beyond anything
Trump even remotely attempted to
maintain via just pure executive power
and actually Trump's use of executive
power is nowhere near even what Obama's
was in ability to get border policy P
literally had him using executive power
to to March the military down to the
border to do border policy I mean I mean
Joe Biden literally used the
occupational safety and Hazard
Administration to try to cram down vax
mandates on 80 million Americans that's
insane sure literally said I cannot
relieve student loan debt and then tried
to
relieve hundreds of billions of dollars
in stud but what happened to that it got
struck down by the sueme court and then
they still did it they still did it
Biden brags about
it for what he for what he was able to
for what he was able to relieve which I
think were related to particular type
student loan debt but I'm just saying
that like well the guard rails are
holding with Biden as much as they're
holding with Trump the only difference
is is that once Biden you know exhausts
his executive power he's not running
around like lying to people or trying to
extort people or trying to and talk
insane schemes well I mean so here
here's the way I would think of this
think of the guard rails holding as the
filter okay meaning like the the coffee
is in the filter some of it's you know
what you want is going to get through
and all the stuff the guard rails
prevent the other stuff from getting
through now the question becomes what
liquid are you pouring into the filter
okay meaning so if I if I'm if if the
filter exists if the guard rails hold
and if Donald Trump can't steal
elections what's the policy that comes
through the other end of the filter the
policy I get from Donald Trump on the
other end of the filter is a bunch of
stuff that I like the policy that I get
from Joe Biden on the other end of the
filter is a bunch of I don't so
that's the basic calculation okay so so
then the idea is essentially that Donald
Trump's rhetoric is insane but we don't
care um Donald Trump would probably try
to steal an election if he could but he
probably won't be able to um he's not
going to do it again I told you he's not
you don't you don't think he has any why
not because he won't be eligible to be
on the ballot in I mean by the way you
want to talk about 14th Amendment that's
where the 14th amendment applies okay
that that's where it actually applies
meaning you cannot he is not qualified
to be on the ballot in 2028 if he is the
president of the United States states
literally in self-executing fashion take
him off the ballot just like he's past
the age of 35 once you have been
president two times you're no longer
eligible to be president of the United
States why have a strong little keep off
the B why the why would the 14th
Amendment stop if he thought vice
president Pence could unilaterally
decide the outcome of the
election when he's not on the ballot so
so now now your theory is that he's
goingon to get he's going to get
reelected and then in 2028 he's not even
going to be on the ballot and he's going
to direct his new vice president car
Lake to Simply declare him president of
the United States when he has not been
on a ballot I don't know what the I
don't know what the scheme would be I
think we can kind of like laugh and say
there's no scheme we could even concoct
but I think like with the machine gun
he's going to walk into I think I think
the issue though is that like the idea
of electing another president that has
tried to circumvent the peaceful
transfer of power using extra legal
means and then pretending like we can't
concoct a single scheme that he could
try to circumvent um other legal
processes to have a third term or to
have a longer term or to uh install who
he wants as the next president I just
when a when a person is already shown
you who they are and with every single
person around him agrees with that when
every single person that's worked with
him save for the what Sydney Powell uh
Eastman and Giuliani which I don't think
even I don't think anybody would want to
throw their lot in with those three um
it just seems wild to me that we would
say like yeah we're just going to go
ahead and trust this guy with another
ter of president but like he can't run
for a third term so it's fine when
there's like 50 million other things
I'll make you the case that if you want
him not to make election trouble you
should elect him president in the next
election cycle and then he will be in
eligible that okay well I find that to
be a wholly unconvincing argument
okay